[ __ ] the very first time I set a rhyme  where I started this paper out I started  not knowing anything what I want to say  and then it wrapped up perfectly and it  ran perfect I was like  oh I just busted enough I was like that  was so much fun that was like Godly I  just made something out of thin air  didn't exist poof it was wrapped up in a  tight little bowl and I was like that's  it for me and then freestyling was like  my [ __ ] [ __ ] and I did it all the  time you know we used to grow up with  alcoholic parents whooping the [ __ ] out  of us imagine if we grew up with like  some pothead parents like giggling and  cooking in the kitchen board games  eating snacks yeah  oh yeah [ __ ] gang [ __ ]  oh my God oh my God  [Music]  oh my God here we go yeah [ __ ] gang  [ __ ] like  oh my God oh my God oh  [Music]  my God